[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a la entrevista de
Franz 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña soy la América Ortega
Mauricio hija de Rosario Mauricio la
vicepresidenta de Nicaragua e hijastra
del presidente nicaragüense Daniel
Ortega es socióloga y participa además
en organizaciones defensoras de Derechos
Humanos soy la América Muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de Franz 24
Gracias por invitarme Gracias por tener
a Nicaragua
en sus preocupaciones y en su agenda
Comencemos Por una parte de su historia
que vamos a marcar luego por supuesto en
la de su país en mayo de 1900 un 98
usted acusaba de manera pública a su
padrastro Daniel Ortega de haber abusado
sexualmente de usted desde que era una
niña Qué pasó a partir de ese momento
Cómo cambió su vida
romper Silencio en 1998 hace más de dos
décadas cuando todavía el tema del abuso
sexual y de los Derechos a las mujeres
no estaban en el desarrollo que tienen
hoy tuvo para mí un costo muy alto
porque desde aquel momento
el sistema jurídico no estaba preparado
para recibir algo como lo que yo hablé
sin embargo creo que
haber roto el silencio definitivamente
me dio
el acto de libertad más importante para
mi vida pero al mismo tiempo la la
oportunidad me obligó a a tener
lecciones
como aquellas que se vinculan a que el
primer ámbito de Justicia es el que una
se da a una misma sin embargo debo decir
que la violencia política hoy en
Nicaragua
que ha ensayado los mismos métodos con
los que en algún momento yo tuve que
lidiar como persecución y venganza por
lo que viví por lo que hablé
implica también el el haber tenido que
renunciar que perder mi país haber
tenido que volver y empezar una y otra
vez
y haber tenido sobre todo que
sobrellevar
las pérdidas tanto las familiares como
las patrimoniales y las más importantes
las las de la identidad para empezar una
nueva vida eso siempre es difícil y
desgraciadamente no todo lo logran y hoy
nos toca a más de uno aprender a vivir
este momento
voy a leer a una ahora una cita suya
Usted dijo cuando el padrastro es el
presidente cuando el padrastro tiene el
poder todo el país es su casa esto dijo
usted en el cortometraje titulado
exiliada de la cineasta de nicaragüense
Leonor Zúñiga lo que hoy vemos en
Nicaragua con la persecución
encarcelamiento quita de nacionalidad
incluso expulsión del país de opositores
y críticos del gobierno acusados la
mayoría de traición a la patria también
ongs y medios de comunicación cerrados
esa opresión que vive Nicaragua comenzó
en el hogar
definitivamente que
la frase de
que cuando el abusador sexual es
presidente en todo el país en su casa
hoy representa una continuidad en el
cual de alguna forma el régimen ASUME
todo un país
como la casa de la cual puede echar en
la casa de la cual puede decidir
quién puede vivir o no en ella la casa
en las que solo ellos tienen el derecho
a a decidir qué es lo correcto lo
incorrecto e incluso en la casa donde no
se puede pensar diferente
esta práctica de
de llevar lo personal llevar el abuso
del poder a todo un país de la misma
manera en la que un día se pudo haber
en el lugar en la familia es Quizá lo
más lamentable de lo que hoy tenemos
pero que nos conduce a pensar que
definitivamente por eso lo personal es
político y en este sentido
la lucha más importante de los
nicaragüenses es y va a seguir siendo
que nunca más la nación sea el país sea
un botín personal sino que sea de verdad
un patrimonio para todos todos tenemos a
sentir que a derecho a sentir que
Nicaragua es nuestra casa y no es la
casa para un solo Grupo donde se pueda
desde ahí decidir incluso quien no puede
salir de esa casa como es lo que hoy
estamos viendo
usted no contó con el apoyo de su madre
y encima de todo tuvo que dejar el país
una situación que precisamente hoy están
viviendo muchísimos nicaragüenses
opositores a Daniel Ortega siente que de
alguna manera su libertad y la de
Nicaragua están ligadas
hemos tenido
todos y hoy que les ha tocado de forma
muy repentina
a
los a los prisioneros que fueron
liberados y a otras tantas personas que
ha tocado salir y que se vive esta
palabra del destierro con tanta crueldad
significa la pérdida similar a la
pérdida de una madre la madre patria
hablamos cuando nos referimos
al lugar donde nacimos definitivamente
que que para mí eso puede haber
significado a lo largo de Mi historia
una doble pérdida
pero estamos obligados a reconocer como
lo hemos dicho que Nicaragua está en
nosotros nosotros somos un pueblo que
nos tocará como otros hacer construir
nuestra nación desde el lugar donde
estemos Y definitivamente
no quedarnos en en esta muerte civil que
pretende representar la expulsión de
ciudadanos de su propia tierra se
quisiera pensar que al arrebatarnos al
país nos puede hacer renunciar a
nuestros derechos ciudadanos no puede
hacer renunciar al proyecto de vida en
el país sin embargo creo que que a los
nicaragüenses a las nicaragüenses nos
toca un aprendizaje en el que muchos
otros pueblos han tenido que hacer que
es cómo empezamos a ser libre y cómo
empezamos desde fuera a a fundar esa
Nicaragua tratando
incluso de aprender de otras culturas y
de dar pasos certeros hacia el retorno a
regresar y depende de nosotros el tiempo
que que eso nos tome si a mí me han
tomado diez años yo estoy segura que a
los que están Apenas saliendo les va a
tocar menos tiempo pero eso depende como
usted bien lo ha dicho de cómo asumimos
ese reto hay mucho por hacer Fuera fuera
somos más libres para actuar Para
organizarnos para unirnos para hablar y
para empezar a vivir
los proyectos que luego queremos
construir cuando regresemos no estamos
muertos no tenemos por qué renunciar a
la ciudadanía porque también tenemos una
ciudadanía global
usted Por supuesto ha conocido muy de
cerca la pareja Murillo Ortega Pero ha
pasado mucho tiempo y sobre todo mucho
poder acumulado verdad lejos de lo que
muchos creen no que usted por ser hija
de Murillo conoce la dinámica de la
pareja en lo que es todo el ejercicio
del poder Más bien a esta altura los
desconoce
creo que la el poder es una de las cosas
que transforman definitivamente a un ser
humano
tendríamos que hablar de del exceso del
poder como algo que definitivamente
construye
personalidades autoritarias
dictatoriales como también el que nos
quita en el poder nos puede Conducir a
una posición de víctima y de personas
sin sentido de vida
definitivamente que lo que ha pasado en
Nicaragua
puedo
haberlo intuido desde perfiles de
personalidad abusivos es decir que lo
que yo Viví en mi propia experiencia
pudiese ir creciendo hacia lo que hoy
está pero soy parte de esos
nicaragüenses que se sorprenden ante
cuando creemos que que ya no va a haber
otras formas nuevas de hacer violencia y
la volvemos a encontrar creo que que es
muy difícil
decir que uno desconoce del todo aquello
de donde uno ha salido pero Sí
definitivamente que que soy de las más
sorprendidas y además conmovidas por
por este proceso tan difícil no solo de
ver las prácticas sino también de
reconocer el daño que que eso ha tenido
para Nicaragua sobre todo en temas de
odio el tema de de cómo se ha sembrado
un conflicto sin precedentes
para finalizar un mensaje para quienes
todavía resisten en Nicaragua
pensar en en amigos en colegas
En esa familia extendida que yo he
tenido allá de amigos que
y también por qué no
pensar en los que están escondidos todos
tenemos a alguien que resiste en
silencio
decirles que
su silencio
es una forma de
desobedecer hacer coro a las voces
hegemónicas
hasta donde estén hasta allá Nicaragua
saber que
que la esperanza está que va va a
amanecer y que es muy importante que
hagamos la diferencia que no
intentemos pensar que necesitamos tener
también poder destructivo para poder
lograr la libertad
a los que están allá en nuestro abrazo
nuestra admiración y reconocimiento por
por esa resistencia del día a día esos
son nuestros héroes de de la esperanza
para nosotros
soy la América Ortega Mauricio
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de Franz 24 Gracias a
nuestra audiencia le invitamos a seguir
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y no olviden que pueden
escuchar esta y muchas otras entrevistas
en Spotify y también pueden verlas por
supuesto en 24.com
[Música]